[Música]
[Aplausos]
telas
pañuelo
pañal
de los venda barbijo antifaz camiseta
calzoncillo media camisón corpiño y
bombacha
sábanas toallas
primera pantalón camisa bufanda capucha
alpargata vestido tapado
sotana burka talit
funda curita
servilleta cortina
repasador mantel mantilla lona reposera
toldo paraguas paracaídas velas de barco
redes de pesca banderines banderas
telas para él
quien desafía el hecho de pasar un día
en la vida sin tocar una tela
ni de día ni de noche
llegamos al mundo y nos envuelven en un
pañal blanco suave limpio es el mejor
lugar para llegar
y para morir
como momias nos seguimos envolviendo en
telas sean vendas o sean mortajas
porque las telas habiendo tantos
materiales que inventó el ser humano
nada la reemplaza
del cultivo o del animal el ser humano
saco la fibra para hacer un hilo y
comenzar a tramar historias
la tela es un material único es suave es
resistente
es amigo del cuerpo es térmico es
lavable
a cuántas personas conocen sin ropa
ojalá que a muchas
desnudos digo a cuantos
la ropa es nuestra piel social
qué pasaría si yo ahora me saco la ropa
acá ahora
[Aplausos]
hacemos un pacto entre nosotros con la
ropa como piel que rara vez nos animamos
a romper
tenemos que acudir a ciertas sustancias
para poder animarlos a veces a sacarnos
la ropa
la ropa es nuestra piel social es
nuestra cáscara es nuestros pelos y son
nuestras plumas
con la ropa nos construimos en nuestras
identidades con la ropa nos
diferenciamos con la ropa nos seducimos
con la ropa nos uniformamos en roles en
oficios y en creencias
entre sabanas hacemos el amor
entre telas construimos nuestras
familias
y todos los días todas las noches
volvemos a nuestra cuna de tela nuestra
cama
siempre fue así la tela tan importante
siempre porque el textil es prehistórico
la raza humana aprendió a tejer antes
que escribir y tejiendo aprendió mucho
más
tejiendo aprendimos a gestionar y
organizar materiales tejiendo aprendimos
a crear a mezclar mundos materiales con
mundos espirituales y tejiendo
también
nos construimos en nuestras metáforas
hay un cordón que me trae al mundo que
es el cordón umbilical hay un tejido que
es mi piel
qué es un tejido conectado y nosotros
somos una gran trama social
en este momento un textil se está
cargando de mí
de mi transpiración de mis olores de mí
de mi cuerpo y a ustedes les está
pasando lo mismo y más tarde mis
textiles se van a cargar con el perfume
de mis amores ojalá
ojalá que les pase lo mismo
que anida el textil que tiene en esos
recovecos
que guarda además de polvo células adn
si miramos un textil a la lupa veremos
una sucesión increíble de puntos
organizados y moss
que en una secuencia de abrazos se
relacionan unos con otros como en una
especie de telar
componiendo ese todo textil
y si somos una trama
ahora
acá
a ver
ustedes
como sé
podrían relacionar podría ser por las
manos por los brazos a ver probar
bien en un momento hacían algo como una
especie de ola a mí me gustaría que
hagan un telar sigan por favor todos
todos y sabes que porque como no los veo
levanten las manos a ver ahí va ahí va
allá también a ver un telar
eso
a ver si se animan si yo hago flamear
esta bandera humana
tiene que planear hasta el fondo
eso
somos una trama humana viva
muchísimas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]